on
bonjour à tous
à une semaine du premier tour des
élections régionales france 3 bourgogne
et france 3 franche comté bouleverse
leur programme nous allons vous proposer
trois débats thématiques tout au long du
week-end afin de mieux comprendre les
enjeux du scrutin cet après midi à 15
heures 20 on parlera d'environnement et
de politiques énergétiques demain dès
11h nous débattrons de la politique
économique et des projets en matière
notamment de formation professionnelle
mais d'abord ce matin les transports
c'est une des compétences phare des
conseils régionaux cela représente près
d'un quart du budget des institutions en
bourgogne et en franche comté
on va en débattre avec nos invités avec
eric sicaud bonjour eric bonjour vous
allez nous présenter les candidats sur
ce plateau et à commencer par françoise
branger bonjour vous êtes là pour la
liste et l'érudit de françois sauvadet
vous êtes conseillère régionale sortante
et ancien député du doubs michel deniau
en face de vous bonjour bonjour la liste
ps de marie-guite dufay vous êtes
premier vice président sortant du
conseil régional de bourgogne
edouard qu'à 20 pour la liste front
national de sophie montel bonjour je
vous êtes chef de file en côte d'or
philippe hervieu pour la liste europe
écologie les verts bonjour si les
prud'hommes je précise vous êtes vice
président sortant du conseil régional de
bourgogne
nous avons également maxime thibeault
vous êtes la tête de liste de debout la
france pour ces élections régionales en
bourgogne franche comté bonjour à vous
et puis j'ai mis deux roues bonjour vous
tête de liste dans la nièvre pour la
liste alternative à gauche de nathalie
vermorel
alors vous en avez l'habitude cette
émission c'est aussi la vôtre vous
pouvez l'a commentée sur les réseaux
sociaux réagir poser vos questions faire
vos commentaires avec le mode yes qui
s'affiche reg bfc c'est simple comme
régional bourgogne franche comté règles
bfc vos commentaires passeront à
l'antenne alors madame messieurs au
cours de ce débat nous allons débattre
de l'avenir des aéroports de dijon et de
dole du projet de canal entre la saône
et la moselle des transports scolaires
mais d'abord eric pour mettre ce débat
sur de bons rails en quelque sorte on a
parlé des trains oui puisque les
transports donc sont au coeur de
l'action à du conseil régional c'est le
pro
les postes budgétaires avec près de 190
millions par an en bourgogne 140 en
franche comté alors l'essentiel vous
l'avez dit jérémy est consacrée aux ter
les trains express régionaux qui ont été
transférées aux régions des régions
devenue l'autorité organisatrice de
l'intégralité de la mobilité
interurbaines on sait que les
conseillers régionaux ont investi
rénover le parc on sait aussi que des
lignes ont été fermés modifié que
certains usagers ne sont pas contents
alors les conventions ter arrivent à
leur terme en 2016
en bourgogne en 2017 en franche comté ce
qu'il faut en profiter
et bien pour tout revoir avec la sncf
qui ont commencé à manger on va écouter
volontiers puisque les nouvelles
conventions portent je crois sur un
milliard et demi sur cinq ans donc ce
n'est pas une mince affaire et cela
représente un budget plus mon énorme un
quart de l'action d'une région et au
travers les ter s'est beaucoup de choses
se sont beaucoup de choses sur les
financements des matériels roulants de
l'accessibilité des gares de des
déficits d'exploitation justement de
l'ensemble des ter rien à peu près 600
par jour il faut quand même le dire mais
malgré tout on attend de la sncf
une régularité de la ponctualité et puis
aussi de l'information
alors on sait bien que une majorité de
trains arrivent à l'heure mais quand
même beaucoup de nos concitoyens se
plaignent chaque fois et avec la sncf
nous n'avons quand même pas beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre puisque c'est le seul
opérateur en france et que nous n'avons
pas le choix et que aujourd'hui
eh bien nous les ter coûte à peu près
20% de plus que chez nos voisins
européens
par exemple les allemands quelquefois on
peut dire même 40% sur certaines lignes
alors vous pouvez imaginer si les ter
coûtait 20 % de moins quelles sont les
économies que nous pourrions réaliser
pour pour hôte d'autres politiques donc
la volonté c'est bien de renégocier avec
la sncf
justement ces conventions qui arrive à
échéance l'année prochaine justement est
ce que françois soit aider disait que le
coup le train coûte trop cher est-ce
qu'il faut remettre la pression sur la
sncf
vous avez dit quelque chose d'essentiel
dans la présentation tout à l'heure
c'était au change
nous ne sommes plus avec les compétences
uniquement dr avec sa 130 trains par
jour 200 car nous sommes avec une
compétence qui va nous échoit au 1er
janvier 2017 qui a la compétence de
l'ensemble de la mobilité et il faut
parler de la mobilité plutôt que des
moyens nous sommes nous sommes nous
sommes dans une situation où les choses
changent ou les habitudes de transport
change et la problématique de meubles la
mobilité est à la fois une problématique
sociale une problématique
environnementale un certain nombre de
nos concitoyens n'ont pas de moyen de
transport n'ont pas de solution ce qui
les éloigne parfois de la formation de
l'emploi
c'est dans le budget des ménages un coût
élevé et au niveau environnemental on
est à quelques jours de la coop 21 et où
effectivement là il ya un enjeu fort en
matière d'énergie et de de faire pour
faire en sorte aussi que l'énergie cela
les transports sont - pau doit donc on
est on est on est dans cette logique là
et par rapport à cela il faut prendre
les choses différemment de ce que nous
avons fait la mobilité la mobilité doit
être partagée si elle doit pas y avoir
une seule solution de mobilité il ya
plusieurs choses une seule mobilité qui
s'enchaînent la mobilité elle doit être
durable
la blonde lui dit elle doit être
connectée c'est à dire que ce c'est la
chaîne de parcours qui est important et
la cncef ne s'y trompe au niveau
national quand guillaume pepy a annoncé
au début de l'année la volonté de faire
une offre de service de porte à porte
etc cela les enjeux futurs
alors on peut très bien parler des
trains qui n'arrivent pas en retard
j'arrive en retard on peut parler de
tout ce moment de location en
négociations avec la sncf
je pense que le choix politique d'avenir
c'est savoir comment se positionne sur
ces nouvelles compétences que nous
allons avoir qui vont nous le choix
comment la nouvelle région les prend en
compte et comment c'est l'ensemble de la
chaîne de mobilité que l'on prend en
compte qui va de la marche à pied
jusqu'à l'avion edouard qu'avant on va
revenir sur les trains est ce que pour
vous le réseau actuel est satisfaisant
non tout d'abord il n'est pas
satisfaisant mais je vais revenir sur ce
qu'a dit michel neugnot c'est assez
intéressant d'écouter quelqu'un nous
expliquer qu'il faut changer les choses
alors qu'il est au pouvoir depuis des
années voire des décennies dans la
région donc je trouve ça assez étonnant
et je pense que les téléspectateurs ne
s'y tromperont pas quand on nous parle
de changement alors qu on est aux
commandes c'est assez déroutant j'allais
dire non le réseau n'est pas
satisfaisant on nous parle de
désenclavement des territoires la
plupart du temps je note que le ps a
voté la restriction du nombre de paix
vers dans la nièvre notamment donc nous
parle de désenclavement mais c'est pas
du tout la réalité qui est qui est opéré
aujourd'hui je pense notamment aux 6 à
la voix unique qui s'exerce entre dole
pontarlier et lausanne qui créent des
tas de retard alors que les suisses nous
demandent de coopérer pour investir pour
qu'il y ait deux voies de train ce qui
paraît la moindre des choses dans la
période actuelle en termes de transport
quand je pense qu'il est très important
de parler de la sécurité des transports
nous sommes favorables à la création
d'une police régionale des transports
ce qui n'est pas ce qui ne serait pas
une chose unique en france ça existe et
ça a été testé dans des endroits dans
des endroits différents par mois et ça
fonctionne très bien
je pense notamment aux six au tgv rhin
rhône
on nous avait promis la création de 5000
emplois et finalement c'est pas du tout
le cas parce que la plupart des
travailleurs une grande partie hindoue
du moins sont des travailleurs détachés
venant de pays notamment de l'europe de
l'est
donc tout ça c'est un petit peu un vaste
ont soulagé quand j'entends parler de
changement je pense que le seul
changement qui le seul changement qui
est incarné aujourd'hui c'est par la
liste front national
la france entend parler de belles choses
depuis tout à l'heure mais les gens
concrètement quand ils prennent le train
il voit quoi des rideaux dégueulasse il
voit des ran qui sont sales et je parle
du dijon chalon sur saône par exemple
moi je les prix allaient retour pendant
cinq ans que pendant mes études
bon dès le matin 6 heures du matin de
lundi matin bon dès le dimanche soir à
19 heures et je peux vous dire une chose
monsieur neugnot
c'est que avec les autres étudiants on
rêvait de vous voir pour vous dire
monsieur neugnot les chefs de votre
politique entame ferroviaire c'est
inadmissible de voir qu'aujourd'hui des
jeunes de mon âge
voyage dans des trains plus vieux qu'eux
et ça c'est une réalité
donc on peut parler de mobilité en terme
général nationaux niaux mais si
concrètement le service public n'est pas
assurée avait une qualité avec la wii
fit avec l'électricité dans le train
comment voulez vous que les gens
utilisent et quand on parle des retards
je voi 9% de retard de plus de cinq
minutes
combien de fois des étudiants le
vendredi soir en voulant prendre le
train dijon chalon se sont retrouvés
bloqués à dijon avec une heure
d'attentats voir avant d'avoir un
véhicule de substitution ou un bus pour
pouvoir rentrer chez eux ça c'est des
faits réels et moi c'est avant le drame
de la sncf ou de la région mais c'est de
la faute de la sncf parce que sa
direction régionale doit agir mais c'est
de la faute de la région ne pas se
réveiller et le problème c'est quand
vous venez passion de terrain ne vous
prenez pas le train comment vous pouvez
savoir ce qui se passe donc moi je bats
c'est rarement des conseils de jeunes
finir détendez vous les idées là je suis
très important d'assurer un contrôle
beaucoup plus strict de l'argent donné
par la région à la sncf et c'est la
moindre des choses
philibert yeux vous sur cette question
des transports c'est sûr que là il faut
il faut quand même comprendre que on
subit aujourd'hui l'abandon d'une
politique ferroviaire telle qu'elle
était de passer on a mis tous sur le tgv
on a tout mis sur les routes la région
d'une certaine manière a suivi puisque
l'ami beaucoup beaucoup d'argent sur les
routes pendant cette dernière mandature
et puis quand à la précédente et du coup
on se retrouve je suis d'accord avec
monsieur thibault on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec des trains qui sont
vieillissants avec des trains qui sont
pas moderne et avec des lignes qui sont
bondées à certaines heures dont ils sont
investis
votre parti fait partie de l'exécutif
sortir en bourgogne et en franche-comté
attend aussi on a pas on a pas on est
responsable on a toujours voté des
budgets et on est solidaire de la
majorité mais au moins on n'a pas arrêté
de dire qu' il fallait mettre beaucoup
plus d'argent dans les ter beaucoup
moins d'argent dans les routes et qu' il
fallait faire attention à 7 à cette
nouvelle mobilité qui est en cours et
qu'on n'a pas vu venir complètement mais
c'est pas simplement une faute de la
région c'est aussi une faute de l'état
qui à un moment donné à tous mais encore
une fois sur les routes sur les lgv et
ça continue puisque quand on veut faire
le lyon turin
ça nous touche un petit peu puisque on
fait partie de l'association l'an turin
quand on veut mettre des milliards dans
l'union turin quand on veut mettre des
milliards on va parler tout à l'heure du
grand canal quand monsieur sauvadet nous
dit qu'il veut mettre des milliards dans
le grand canal ça veut dire qu'on va pas
le mettre sur les trains et donc ça
c'est une véritable question parce que
aujourd'hui les problèmes de on a des
problèmes de mobilité parce que le coût
de la sncf est trop cher le billet est
trop cher pour pour pour lui et pour les
gens qu'ils empruntent au quotidien que
ce soit des étudiants ou des gens qui
vont travailler mais il faut aussi
parler de la question environnementale
enjeux des transports aujourd'hui au
moment de la coop 21 c'est quand même un
enjeu environnemental de gaz à effet de
serre et de transition et de changement
climatique puisque les transports ces 27
% des gaz à effet de serre et de la
problématique gère votre voisin droit de
lille s'est pas exprimé jusqu'à présent
un petit dessus et et monsieur doriot
est venu me semble-t-il en train depuis
la nièvre je suis venu en train et jeudi
les terreurs voilà et non il n'était pas
un problème est effectivement un
problème lié à la sncf
1 j'ai demandé pourquoi pourquoi le le
train était en retard et il y avait un
problème de signalisation qui a bloqué
bloquer le train ce qui va arriver ce
qui peut arriver bien sûr mais a priori
ce problème n'était lié qu'à un manque
d'entretien
voilà tout simplement
et la sncf aujourd'hui est tellement
soumises à des contraintes de
rentabilité à la perspective de
l'ouverture la libéralisation la
concurrence qu'est ce que comporte plus
du tout comme un service public
elle ne cherche maintenant que kaka
faire des profits est en tout cas
l'enjeu maintenant c'est qu'elles
redeviennent c'est qu'elle sait qu'elle
redevienne une vraie entreprise publique
chargée de deux guitares mission de
service public ont ces régionales alors
dans le rôle du du conseil régional si
on peut revenir en arrière c'est vrai
qu'on est tout de suite parti sur sur
les propositions et moi je vais bien
parler aussi du bilan il ya des
religions responsable d'ailleurs voilà
effectivement puisque notamment c'est
mon ami ni jean paul pinaud du front de
gauche qui était vice président aux
transports et avant lui en bourgogne
bien sûr oui mais et avant lui jean
claude le bras lui aussi communiste et
le bilan c'est quand même que depuis
2004 30 % 30 % de fréquentation en plus
donc effectivement il ya encore des
progrès à faire encore des efforts à
faire
mais tout ça effectivement il faut ça ça
passe aussi par une remise en cause des
politiques d'austérité actuellement
j'aimerais qu'on revienne à à vous
madame branger vous avez dit tout à
l'heure le train coûte trop cher
aujourd'hui quand on perd un billet de
train ça représente 17 % du coût total
du transport en franche comté une
trentaine de pour cent en bourgogne
c'est à dire que c'est un moyen de
transport déjà hyper subventionné mais
on entend ici et là que finalement ça
manque de trains ça manque de
d'aménagement alors est-ce que c'est
compatible réduire un budget et
augmenter l'offre de services je crois
qu'il faut regarder tous les moyens de
transport aussi puisque il y a il n'y a
pas que le transport par train il ya
aussi par autocar et niestlé ligne viveo
aussi qui dépendent directement de la
sncf ça veut dire que pour réduire le
budget transport vous annonce transférer
des trajets des lignes de train sur vers
les justes je n'ai absolument pas dit ça
j'ai dit que la sncf
je pas du tout écoutez je pense que nous
devons et nous allons faire pression sur
la sncf pour faire baisser le coût des
ter parce que plus largement c'est le
modèle le modèle sncf le modèle
économique qui n'est plus tout à fait
viable chez nous parce que les lésions
de connectivité de ce fonds à l'étranger
et il n'est pas normal que tout
l'ensemble des ter du réseau des des
matériels repose exclusivement sur les
régions ce n'est pas possible
la sncf organise elle-même sa propre
concurrence moi je suis très colère
quand je vois effectivement les autocars
qui sont qui viennent en concurrence
directe avec les ter alors on demande
aux régions de payer les ter et la sncf
que va-t-elle faire demain et bien elle
va m elle va mettre des autocars et 46
villes desservies dont je vous ai pris
cette publicité que j'ai reçues par
internet
moi je regrette mais à un moment il faut
revoir notre modèle en entier sur le
territoire français n'est acceptable que
nous deux nous devions payer autant
d'argent pour les ter et que
parallèlement la sncf organise sa propre
que la vessie chez nous à la chaîne
audio excusez moi je voudrais quand même
réagir
là on a près après s'ils participeraient
les dauphins ce paradigme lesquels un
système vicié ne nous a effectivement
c'est pas paradoxal d'ouvrir les lignes
sncf à la concurrence des bus tout en
demandant aux régions de financer les
trains faut mettre de l'ordre
j'entends tout ce qui était dit j'aurais
dit à monsieur cava que je me suis en
perspective de la nouvelle loi la loi
note qui bat donner la compétence de
toute la mobilité le long somme de la
chaîne
laissez moi je vous ai écoutés vous
auriez peut-être je vis tes d'inves je
vous ou nouvellement du cora je vous ai
si la loi notre infirmière j'ai bougé
écoutez vous donnant la parole après
vous me répondrez quand j'entends pour
ce bashing il faut quand même revenir
les pieds sur terre
vaches dont certains trains sur donc je
me mets moi nous mettons avec marie du
fait en perspective de la loi nome
qui donnera compétences à la région pour
l'ensemble des solutions de mobilité à
partir du 1er janvier 2017
donc c'est cela l'avenir c'est ça le
changement on est dans un autre domaine
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne la sncf
actuellement et le développement c'est
dû dire fort justement développement de
plus de 30% des usages 30% s'était fait
par une politique qui a été menée avec
les moyens que l'on avait qui a permis
de d'avoir ce résultat 3 troisième
événement madame madame nous avons la
compétence des ter depuis 2002 vous ne
pouvez pas vous retournez en disant
c'est l'état qui doit faire assumons nos
compétences faisons le et faisons avec
les moyens que nous avons
troisième autre élément pendant 40 ans
on s'est totalement désintéressé de
l'entretien des voies on arrive à des
solutions où effectivement des troncs
sanquer entre paray-le-monial et la mûre
en direction de lyon d'être en chantier
ou lé 10 à 30 à l'heure sur des dizaines
de kilomètres
j'ai un effort considérable qui est fait
depuis deux ans avec une multiplication
par quatre de l'ensemble des travaux sur
les gros tricks qui amène énormément qui
amène énormément de perturbations ils
vont alors s'il vous plaît maxime
thibeault vous souhaitez réagir et
donner ces éléments là où les jolies
simon joue à la solution alors parce que
match aller la solution c'est d'avoir
une vraie logique là on a vu investir
46,6 millions 46 8 millions d'euros pour
refaire le corail
en quoi vous l'avez fait avant la fusion
des régions vous savez que vous allez
sclérosé la fusion des régions
elle vous allez nous obliger à attendre
cinq ou six ans avant de recommencer
vous auriez pu attendre la fusion se
fasse vous qui parlez de la loi note
vous avez temps voulu avant d'investir
le deuxième point sur lequel je
intervenir c'est le paradigme c'est à
dire la manière de penser de service
public la manière de penser de service
public un service public il n'est pas là
pour être rentable il est là pour servir
le public est aujourd'hui le vrai
problème
c'est vous madame vous monsieur vous
avez signé les mêmes accords européens
qui vous conterai une part l'obligation
de libéraliser l'ensemble de nos
services specifar niveau traduit
localement et il faut assumer les
décisions de ces partis politiques et il
ne faut pas venir dire on va faire un
meilleur service public
si vous interdisez en france une logique
de service public il y avait quand même
quelque chose dont on n'a pas encore
parlé jusqu'à maintenant qui s'appelait
la taxe poids lourds vous voulez bien
sûr qu'on veut le réintroduire c'était
une taxe qui permettait de financer
on parlait de financement les moyens
aujourd'hui pour financer le ter et le
train vers ce qui est en train de se
dire concrètement qu'il faut remettre en
route cette cette affaire de taxe poids
lourds de manière à moderniser les
équipements ferroviaires aujourd'hui on
n'a pas les moyens sans cette taxe et je
crois qu'il faut la remettre au goût du
jour la droite
si vous revenez aux affaires a instauré
une taxe poids lourd régional tu
exactement la droite alain guérin et la
gauche s'est lui offert
oui la gauche et la gauche a reculé sur
cette affaire ah c'est pour ça que nous
voulons et ses bruits mais ces gouttes
il faut revenir à continuer avec un
niveau de fret mis sur les poids lourds
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui on ne
pourra pas continuer avec un niveau de
service pour les particuliers dans les
ter et pour les trains de tous les jours
comme on est aujourd'hui donc il va
falloir trouver des financements il faut
arrêter l'hypocrisie
ces financements ne pourrait être trouvé
qu'au travers d'une nouvelle taxe poids
lourd régional qui serait mise en place
assez rapidement
nous avons aussitôt de propositions que
celles ci parce que c'est ces centrales
on l'a vu il ya besoin de vraiment de
d'un financement pour le pour le
transport ferroviaire et on voit revenir
aussi sur le fret et
au front de gauche on en a quatre un
versement de transport pour un versement
transport pour les régions à une taxe
sur les entreprises qui bénéficient de
toute façon à des six il bénéficie des
infrastructures de transport donc c'est
juste qu'elle est aussi participent dans
les agglomérations en ile de france
ça existe déjà en ile de france donc on
veut l'élargir toutes les régions
entreprises et la reprise compréhension
de la reprise la reprise par l'état de
la dette aussi de réseau ferré de france
puisque en ce moment réseau ferré de
france se paye un milliard d'intérêts
tous les ans aux banques
ce milliard d'intérêts forcément il est
pas mis dans ses investissements sur le
réseau 44 milliards troisième solution
la création aussi d'un livret à livret a
sur le transport comme c'est fait déjà
pour le pour le logement et une dernière
proposition faite par l'intermédiaire
d'une proposition de loi je le répète la
la taxation des maxi profit des
autoroutes
on a offert les autoroutes à des grandes
compagnies privées qui font 2 milliards
de bénéfices par an le pourcentage ont
privatisé
nominé pour reprendre un petit peu sur
les autoroutes c'est vrai que c'est
scandaleux les privations beaucoup
critiqué mais quelles sont vos
propositions en matière de transports
alors pour le cas de l'autoroute
c'est un petit peu complexe il faudrait
renationaliser ça passera pas besoin de
nationaliser ce sont des délégations de
services publics et les concessions peu
c'est pas de se récupérer les ordinaires
bénéfices que font ces sociétés et non
pas les investir en achetant des
immeubles en faisant de la spéculation
immobilière plus tolérer investir dans
l'infrastructure edouard qu'elle vient
justement les investissements vous vous
êtes pour plus augmenter le budget
consacré au thé vert ou pas et si oui
comment vous le financer mais oui il
faut augmenter le budget consacré aux
ter et notamment il ne faut pas
supprimer des voix comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
un entretien doit être optimisé notre 1
le contrat de plan etat-région de sony
notamment être la suppression de l'aide
les deux contrats etat/région ya un
volet cents chefs qui est très important
je vais pas vous citer tous mais en
revanche pas cédé aux pressions des
relations est classé sncf qui se sont
dégradées donc c'est très important de
garder la relation beaucoup plus elle
mais avec un contrôle beaucoup plus
strictes au niveau de ce qui est fait
par la sncf aujourd'hui le contrôle avec
la sncf il a lieu mais pas ses coûts un
seul chiffre
si nous avions laissé filer la
convention bourgogne la contribution dès
qu'ils seraient aujourd'hui 275 millions
elle est à 142 millions
là non plus un travail qui a été fait
très fin avec la sncf
et ce n'est pas forcément mettant des
trains partout paulo répond aux besoins
sans mi-temps lé bon train au bon moment
mais un autre projet s'il vous plaît
chez vous dire j'ai su revenir
mais quand même une candidate qui est
sortant en franche comté et qui étaient
à la manoeuvre
et justement les contrats d'objectifs
qui ont été acceptées par la région
franche comté ont augmenté d'une manière
exponentielle chaque année c'est à dire
de 4 millions d'euros
et je trouve moi personnellement on les
a pas suffisamment négocier donc
ce bilan là si vous voulez transposer à
l'arrière la grande région
ben moi je suis pas tout à fait comme à
la sncf parce qu'il faut faire pression
avec la sncf
il faut effectivement payer un peu moins
cher les ter vous savez quand même que
les recettes c'est quand même pas grand
chose dans un budget qui fait quand même
331 milliards millions pardon d'euros
les recettes représentent assez peu de
choses
j'écris à gc 320 millions total du
service et les recettes c'est 98
je suis d'accord mais 225-73 déficit
d'exploitation de déficit d'exploitation
commun des choses raisonnables et
essayer d'avoir pour nos concitoyens
effectivement une offre réguler plus tôt
plutôt à voir madame mission descendu
cran s'il vous plaît aidez
l'autre gros de ses nuits avec les
autocars aussi parce que il faudra quand
même ratio je démissionne mais s'il vous
plaît
personne ne vous entend personne ne vous
en passer l'autre gros dossier transport
l'autre gros dossier transporte cette
campagne c'est l'aéroport de dole dans
le jura pour résumer celui de dijon
après de gros investissements du conseil
régional s'est écrasé on peut dire comme
ça et dole a pris son envol avec des
lignes low cost très largement financé
par le conseil départemental du jura
aujourd'hui le conseil départemental
souhaite que cet aéroport soit gérée par
la nouvelle région alors est-ce qu'il
doit le faire et ce qu'on doit
est ce que le conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté doit financer
des lignes low cost notamment et des
départs en vacances finalement pour nous
autres noms bignon et franc-comtois ça
c'est bien je veux bien répondre puisque
c'était aéroports qui est quand même au
centre de la grande région
moi je pense qu'il a vocation à être
aéroport international est justement à
rendre service à nos concitoyens on voit
bien les
et les passagers ont augmenté chaque
année on arrive à une belle
fréquentation
c'est bien qu'il réponde à un besoin
donc nous finançons des thés verts nous
finançons une offre de transport c'est
effectivement par par avion mais je
pense que il a son utilité
et justement nous sommes au coeur de
l'europe nous devons avoir un
rayonnement européen
donc au delà de ça nous allons financer
madame du feu n'a toujours été plutôt
évasive un jour une année on finance on
donne cent cinquante mille euros l'année
suivante 300000 l'année suivante
absolument rien c'est quand même pas
très très logique dans le fonctionnement
donc je ne sais pas ce que vous
souhaitez faire tout un vrai je
souhaiterais tu fais du fait monsieur
père ni dans sa prison au conseil
général n'ont jamais été capables de
travailler ensemble et ça crée une vraie
gabegie financière l'aéroport il a un
intérêt néanmoins il faut concevoir jeu
ce n'est pas comme lyon saint-exupéry il
ya la souris à l'éléphant
donc il faut rester dans un cadre
régional et l'importance des 39e malgré
l'augmentation du nombre de passagers
c'est le 39e aéroports français dole oui
mais ça normal ça tu as il faut vraiment
mais je replace tout à fait mais il faut
bien rester dans une dans une logique
quand même d'échelle et moi je pense
qu'il a un intérêt sur le point de vue
touristique et aussi sur le plan du
développement économique
les suisses sont en recherche de foncier
pour s'installer on pourrait développer
une ligne entre lausanne et dole tavaux
c'est très intéressant mais il ya un
vrai os dit qu'il faut hélas il ya une
gabegie financière 4 millions d'euros
par an c'est inadmissible
et c'est de la faute des socialistes
philibert violent vous vous êtes battus
contre le projet renaissance qu'on a
appelée renaissance pour l'aéroport de
dijon ça a été un échec la du conseil
régional c'est aéroport de dijon le
final sur le philippe hervieu est ce que
vous l'avez vous soutenez s'était
embarquée c'est vrai connaît une
fréquentation croissante
bien sûr que non mais on s'est battu
contre l'aéroport de dijon on se battra
contre celui de dole tavaux pour deux
raisons la première pour des raisons
écologiques
là on continue de raisonner aujourd'hui
au moment de la coop 21 c'est à dire
comment on en train de se dire le climat
risque de changer manière considérable
on pourra pas revenir en arrière
va assister une acidification des océans
une montée des eaux à des réfugiés
climatiques en nombre et par millions et
nous on continue de fin nous la droite
visiblement qu'un thynnus de réfléchir
comme avant c'est à dire qu'on fait en
développe un aéroport international
on sait de marrakech dole en train non
mais ok l'attendait position de gaz et
la question du climat c'est rien du tout
je le sais vous avez vous considérez
comme ça j'ai dit que ces 2 % les gaz et
j'observe ce que dit la droite ne sait
pas ce que les vestes j'aime la fin du
nucléaire le retour du charbon est ce
que c'est donc je dis qu'il ya un enjeu
climatique
on ne prend pas en compte et c'est
dramatique 1,2 sur la question du modèle
économique
il y était pas à dijon on nous avait
promis en 2005
deux cent mille passagers en 2015 en
2011 on en avait 40 milles qui est en
est et qui sait quel est le groupe
politique qui a toujours dit que le
modèle économique n'y était pas c'est à
dire qu'on n'était pas dans un bassin de
population suffisant pour faire
fonctionner l'aéroport on a été le seul
et pendant des années et pendant
pratiquement une décennie à dire
attention le modèle économique n'y est
pas et c'est pour ça que l'aéroport de
dijon a échoué et s'est cassé la figure
l'aéroport de dole j'ai pas fini les
retours de lancers sont quand même
est-ce qu'une
régions comme la bourgogne franche comté
qui souhaitent être apte à attractive
économiquement peut se passer d'un
aéroport la région bourgogne franche
comté va être la plus petite région de
l'ensemble des très très des 13 régions
jusque avec un pib très faible
l'attractivité économique elle doit
développer
on ne doit pas singer les gros on doit
trouver un nouveau mode de développement
on a une région qui a des particularités
qui est peu dense qui a une richesse
faible mais qui a beaucoup d'atouts et
c'est sa seat ou là qu'il faut
développer et on pourra pas mettre tout
notre argent sur tous les sujets il faut
développer les trains les trains du
quotidien il faut remettre en place des
lignes il faut réinvestir dans les
trains il faudrait investir dans
l'intermodalité on pourra pas en même
temps tout faire je sais qu'on est
supérieur électoral où on peut tout
promettre
sauf que on pourra pas tout faire j'ai
encore une chose à dire c'est creed
oui non mais c'est que cet aéroport de
dole c'est le même sujet on n'y arrivera
pas et puis il ya quand même une
troisième chose qu'il faut dire ici
c'est que le low cost
aujourd'hui avec des compagnies que je
citerai pas mais c'est quand même un
modèle social qu'on ne peut pas accepter
on ne peut pas accepter le modèle social
de ryanair par exemple où les hôtesses
de l'air je lisais un bouquin qui a été
fait par une hôtesse de l'air récemment
ou en fait elle est payée sur 35 heures
à l'amphi 70 donc été le cas quand même
qu'il faut se poser ces questions-là
edouard calandre à la différence de
front national
fait pour financer le transport à lille
on sent même très décevant sans même
qu'il est indispensable
nous avons là et vous êtes c'est moi
même je ne vous ai pas pu gérer ces mois
par des noms c'est à côté
nous sommes pour financer les l'aviation
évidemment car nous pensons que c'est
très important pour le rayonnement
économique est en tout cas faire des
affaires notamment avec des pays proches
monsieur thibault parler tous adorent de
la suisse effectivement on peut
éventuellement faire des coopérations
très importante avec la suisse alors je
note que monsieur sauvadet a totalement
lâché l'aéroport de dijon tout comme le
conseil régional au maintien des deux
aéroports
alors forcément les mêmes et pas
forcément a lâché 1 comme ça d'un coup
alors qu'il y avait et il y avait eu
plus de 50 millions d'euros d'investis
dedans quand même c'est ça le problème
quand on investit 50 millions d'euros à
peu près ça à peu près quand on a
investi 50 millions d'euros à perte
on peut pas se permettre de tout
abandonner comme ça du jour au lendemain
surtout qu'il ya des terrains très
important autour de la mort de
l'aéroport de dijon est ce qu'on peut
laisser deux structures à quelques
kilomètres l'une de l'autre
alors c'est très complexe je suis assez
d'accord il faut faire un audit
extérieur notamment par des par des
cabinets qui sont spécialisés au niveau
de l'aéroport des aéroports etc pour
voir ce qu'il ce qu'il convient le mieux
mais je crois qu'il est très important
de développer notamment l'aviation
d'affaires qui est totalement laissés
pour compte aujourd'hui au profit du low
cost et des vols charters louable
alors aujourd'hui principalement à dole
mais on peut tout à fait imaginer que ça
soit maintenue sur dijon c'est tout à
fait envisageable
monsieur qui dit aviation d'affaires dit
rapport aux financements plus grande
implication des chambres de commerce et
d'industrie pour l'instant voilà on dit
on se demande on demande aux régions est
ce que vous voulez investir dans les
aéroports et bat pour nous il faut un
aéroport régional
même si on sait que notre région est
bordé déjà de plusieurs grands grands
aéroports mais pour l'aviation
d'affaires il en faut un si si c'est que
si on dit aviation d'affaires il faut
effectivement une implication plus
grande des échanges commerciaux de tous
les acteurs locaux mais
mais l'on vit même si georges si je peux
finir de la côte de nuits qui est l'un
d'eux mêmes de la loi notre
effectivement donne cette compétence à
la région l'aménagement du territoire
doit rester aussi sur des grandes
questions comme ça à faire de l'état et
là aussi l'état doit avoir un avis à
donner et voire même aidé mais on
continue à financer les lignes low cost
également au sud au nom bien sûr assez
bien sûr que c'est pas le modèle que
l'on vous colle dès que l'on cherche un
modèle en cours c'est le modèle en cours
c'est sûr mais on voit bien que céline
ne marche qu'à coups de subventions
publiques
il faut la ligne s'arrête lorsque les
subventions elle est directement dans la
page dans la poche des actionnaires
donc là aussi il ya une renégociation à
avoir avec ces compagnies se donnait on
vous a pas encore entendu sur l'aéroport
il ya eu un échec à dijon
est-ce que vous soutenez l'aéroport de 2
alors déjà je voudrais dire clairement
que la gestion de dijon de projet
renaissance était celui de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie financé par
trois partenaires
je le dis et le redis pour dire aussi
que actuellement dole tavaux et géré par
la cci et keolis dans une structure est
sèche et la compétence est à fumer par
lasser fait encore qui gère le site avec
des financements publics
le principe non mais c'est pas refaire
l'histoire parce que vous dites la
région si ça c'est pas la région est en
première ligne
c'est elle qui gère le nom faux faux nom
est l'ailé louvre
elle était co financeur avec le
département et le grand dijon michel je
reviens le jeu un petit saut les régions
avec les aéroports nous sommes mariés
dufay franche ap triel nous avons été
contre le financement du low cost
jay kay sénat on était contre le
financement du low cost et la franche
comté la finale mais des contributions
très faible au regard et la bourgogne a
refusé dans le projet que classé s'il a
présenté l'arrivée de low cost nous
avons été content pour l'avenir je
voudrais qu'on devait aussi l'état des
lieux la région bourgogne
ça participe participe à trois
structures aéroportuaires saint-yon vous
ne connaissez peut-être pas en saône et
loire une formation la plus un organe de
formation qui travaille avec le dissez
qui est aussi très développés qui est
essentiel au serbe arrange nous sommes
aussi le dents et on vient de financer
la rénovation de la piste pour
l'attractivité locales des entreprises
et et dijon longvic dijon longvic avec
le grand dijon dijon longvic avec le
grand dijon maintenant s'est borné à
tout ce qui est sanitaire notamment des
lignes arrières qui est dedans
l'aviation d'affaires qui vient que
nécessaire et au climat par rapport à
dolce vita
mais par rapport à début j'ai rien dit
jusqu'à présent le problème va se poser
à la fin de la concession c'est à dire
fin 2017 et c'est un sujet qu'il va
pouvoir travailler
la complémentarité sur le sde et de la
proche aéroportuaire de l'ensemble de la
bourgogne franche comté devraient être
mises à plat et réfléchir ce que l'on
veut donc c'est créer j'ai créé un
modèle économique qui soit viable à long
terme ok moi la vie chère un maximum
quand même centrale
et cet atoll donc le jura déjà ne sera
pas oubliée et deuxièmement dans une
logique de développement touristique
parce que votre loi nôtre nous cloisonne
corps mais nous la région bourgogne
franche comté entre paris la métropole
et lyon qui vont avoir énormément
davantage graphiquement voilà et nous on
peut créer un vrai
et tourisme vert un vrai souffle pour
les parisiens et les lyonnais mais c'est
tout l'intérêt de cet aéroport qui sera
situé à cet endroit là au coeur de la
région et je pense qu'on a tout intérêt
à y réfléchir c'est justement c'est
pourtant aujourd'hui c'est des départs
en vacances mise en défaut parce qu'il
mentionnait je préfère la disette n'aime
pas de subventionner moi ton
subventionne des gens qui partent des
habitants de la région bourgogne franche
comté ne me dérange pas à partir du
moment ils payent les impôts dans la
bourgogne franche comté
néanmoins les gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur de la bourgogne franche
comté ne devrait pas être subventionnés
et la loi ne le permet un critère
objectif arif différencier ses seins
tarifs différenciés
on voit ça sur différents services
publics cela est possible et néanmoins
je suis d'accord avec vous monsieur il
faut lutter contre le low cost c'est
inadmissible c'est du moins disant
social
il ya des solutions à chercher à des
solutions à trouver sauf que le modèle
sera beaucoup moins viable mais c'est
pas une sorte de modèle c'est une
histoire de déjà de faire un vrai lundi
d'abord de la division au fond de vision
gaulliste qu'il faut là dessus
ballaman justement si effectivement
c'est un report prend une dimension
internationale il va se développer de
toute façon on peut mais des subventions
publiques jusqu'à une certaine limite on
est en expérimentation donc il faudra
poser deux bébés dans quelques temps
pour voir quelles seront les les la
véritable rentabilité et su au bout de
quelques années il faut trouver un
modèle économique c'est certain mais
aussi faux nous nous souhaitons
développer et puis mettre justement à
proximité une plateforme avec les ter
avec une gare routière que ce soit eu un
pôle d'intermodalité justement pour que
cela puisse fonctionner mais ça commence
à 15 mètres justement
entendez la ville haute et de marquer
mais ce niveau là aujourd'hui c'est
quand même assez scandaleux d'avoir un
aéroport au milieu de rien qui n'est pas
desservi n'y parle on pourrait tout à
fait imaginer des navettes de bus qui
rejoignent jusqu'à la gare qui est
située à peu près 20 km complètement
incroyable qui n'est pas de navette
entre les deux comment font les gens
mais ça prouve toute l'incompétence des
uns et des autres à gérer des dossiers
concrètement comment on fait pour
rejoindre qu'on sait très concret
l'aéroport à la gare
il n'y a aucune solution là c'est
presque déjà nadir de la bêtise
politique et c'est il manque 1 1 comme
on dirait une chaîne dans le mayo lequel
quel pays
qu'est ce que vous allez rechercher si
vous ne voulez pas deux compagnies low
cost vous allez où vous allez chercher
qui pour faire vivre sans moi au delà du
comment dire des départs en vacances je
suis comme je voulais des jeux nous
sommes plutôt favorable à déployer
massivement une aviation d'affaires pour
attirer des investisseurs locaux c'est
l'idée principale que nous développons
et on sait que les suisses notamment
sont prêts à faire des coopérations
certains on parle déjà pour favoriser le
transport inter interpays interrégional
affronte alizé pardon c'est un terme
qu'on t'a dit qu'ils nous sommes très
proches et ça peut se faire tout à fait
ils sont prêts à financer donc on
pourrait tout à fait quand même oui
imaginez des coopérations du financement
mais peut-être très mal et ça
m'étonnerait pas givi d'euros vous qui
êtes de nevers comment vous regardez le
développement d'un aéroport à dole est
ce que vous sentez concerné ou pas du
tout déjà dans votre présentation vous
aviez dit que c'était un gros dossier
l'aéroport et nous ça nous interroge sa
déjà parce que effectivement en termes
de voyageurs pour l'instant c'est quand
même pas le dos si c'est aussi polémique
au delà dans la campagne
voilà polémique je préférerais ce mot là
il se rend compte que vous n'étiez pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous n'aviez
pas tout à fait les mêmes projets pour
césar oui oui c'est vrai maintenant nous
avons bien et nous l'avons dit il faut
quand même
un aéroport régional on étudiera
effectivement avec qui on peut le faire
et si il ya des compagnies qui veulent
bien venir s'installer
on essaiera de voir avec quel travail a
déjà été fait dans le développement
au moment où le département a relancé
cet aéroport de dole ils ont sondé des
compagnies il en effet sauf que
maintenant voyez vous parlez de
départements maintenant on va être une
grande région donc la discussion va être
peut-être différente
c'est là et puis il ya maintenant des
plusieurs chambres de commerce et
d'industrie qui peuvent être intéressés
pourquoi pas effectivement voir aussi
avec nos voisins suisses
donc je crois que on est au début de
l'histoire et c'est ça que c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut dire ici le
conseil régional qui doivent pour san
fermo les jumeaux piloter ce dossier la
piloter mais comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure en liaison quand même avec avec
l'état et les organismes régionaux le
voilà qu'il ne permet pas qu'il ne
permettra pas à l'avenir d'avoir un
déficit sur de nos coachs ya pas
complice qui n'est pas compensée par des
recettes d'exploitation de l'aéroport
il faut se remettre dans son acte il
faut se remettre dans ce contexte là moi
je veux bien tout entendait revenons
réalité il faut justement faire le voilà
et on a trois ans pour traiter de sujets
mais faut pas y aller en disant il ya
cas il faut qu'on va laisser faire les
dernières élections par l'onction des
espèces qu'on n'ait jamais connue en
termes de cet après midi la question du
changement climatique qui est dramatique
selon le giec et sur lequel il faut
prendre des mesures comme la
deuxièmement ça c'est la première fois
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on n'a pas le
modèle économique tous ceux qui ont
essayé d' expérimenter quelque chose que
ce soit à dole où que ce soit à dijon
mais il faut savoir que l'ensemble des
aéroports régionaux sont en déficit
tous ceux qui ont essayé de financer
aéroports régionaux se sont cassé la
figure et ce que j'entends il ya quand
même unanimité ici c'est que tout le
monde veut relancer les aéroports on a
compris que vous étiez que c'est
vraiment chaud j'ai l'impression qu'on
dit
un autre dossier un autre dossier pour
que leur leur tourne vite au nom parle
moins mais il pourrait très exactement
la liaison fluviale avec nouveau projet
de grand canal ou de canal à grand
gabarit
la droite est très favorable à ce projet
alors je crois qu'il faut pas parler de
canal il faut parler des tabors de
liaison fluviale est interconnexion de
bassin dans ce grand dessein fait
beaucoup rigolé cette histoire il faut
pas parler de cadol c'est parce qu'en
fait le mot est hyper connectés ici et
qui est une grand canal mais j'avais
posé la problématique
écoutez vous nous avez parlé de la coop
21 à la com 21
et bien quand même les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre sont générées quand
même de l'ordre de 35% par les
transports et à peu près un peu plus et
et puis les transports de marchandises
sont extrêmement une 45 ou 49 je sais
plus pour cent de des transports il y à
aujourd'hui en france 42 mille morts de
suite à la pollution atmosphérique due
aux particules et c'est donc moi je pose
la question des transports de fret parce
que le transport de fret la sncf notre
opérateur national ne veut plus en faire
on le sait et on le voit bien la diviser
elle a divisé par deux largement tout ce
qui est transporté par le faire et que
on essaye bien de dire qu'on veut faire
on veut faire du fret mais ceci dit les
plus grand tonnage de marchandises des
échanges nord-sud de passe par le pouls
loire franche comté à un moment donné il
faut quand même se poser la question
alors on a fait des infrastructures en
affecter j'y vais pour le transport de
voyageurs
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le
transport de marchandises
les allemands nous annonce le doublement
du fret dans les années 2030 et
aujourd'hui moi je pense que la voie
d'eau peut être
une une possibilité pour le transport de
fret pas pour tout bien évidemment mais
au moins pour accompagner l'augmentation
du fred sur les routes pour éviter que
la voie d'eau
y'a pas que elle sert pas qu'aux
transports elle sert à l'acheminement au
plus haut au coeur des villes également
mais elle produit de l'électricité
elle peut réguler les crues tout ça on a
complètement oublié la france ne pas le
plus via et ne veux plus en parler là
perdu la culture du fluvial et bien moi
je dit non
nos voisins européens sont encore se
chercher sur ce schéma là et encore et
beaucoup de marchandises et il ya plus
de 20 % en allemagne en belgique et
cetera je dis simplement il faut se
réintéresser à la voie fluviale
le team qui va vers moi j'ai
l'impression peut se sauver des voeux le
retour madame voynet en défendant ce
projet c'est quand même aberrant
on nous parle l'allemagne l'allemagne
l'allemagne ont voulu à plusieurs
esquisses pour ce qui n'était pas à
l'époque dominique voynet était vraiment
le gros moteur de ce grand qu'avec sa
carrière politique sur lequel elle
retourne est ce que je veux dire c'est
vous parlez de l'allemagne des aliens
mais où sont les produits français où l
industrie française
à quoi va servir ce grand canal pour
l'industrie française à rien nous a je
remarque que j'aimerais du ce qu'on veut
c'est que l'on va plus forte elle est en
train de mourir je vous rappelle quand
même qu'alstom a été racheté par général
et les préserver ah oui vous avez permis
le rachat d'alstom par général et la
piscine du centre et de l'est chinois
mais cette idée américains portés ces
turbines à gaz et nous appartient vous
savez très bien signer dans une virée
parle du grand canal du grand canal
alors en regard sur ce sujet je sais une
gabegie financière va coûter très très
cher qu'il n'est pas utile je
préfèrerais qu'on se concentre sur le
ferroutage ferroviaire qui me semble
bien plus utile mais qu'elle n'avait
servi à rien mais en france et
l'allemagne passe maintenant par le nord
elles passent de moins en moins par le
sud il faut être très clair donc en
réalité on va faire un grand canal pour
les allemands et même pas pour les
français les allemands n'ont pas besoin
du tout de ce projet de canal
complètement utopiste lancé comme ça et
se lancer un petit peu comme ça de
manière électoraliste par monsieur
sauvadet s'est pas trop pourquoi moi je
pense que c'est purement une lumière
dans son esprit j'ai dit on va dire ça
peut-être que ça fera 2 % +1 35% - june
on n'a pas besoin l'allemagne on n'a pas
du tout besoin avec rotterdam
donc c'est complètement utopique c'est
cesser purement électorales et si on va
quand même pas détruire la belle vallée
du doubs qui est magnifique il devrait
être plus protégés l'étude des rapports
l'occurrence messieurs notamment j'ai
défendu le fret ferroviaire est ce que
vous êtes aussi favorable je vais mais
bien sûr je suis favorable au transport
fluvial
mais là en l'occurrence s'était dit ça
va coûter énormément cher et c'est pas
nous qui le disons c'est la commission
mobilité 21,1 qui déjà qui déjà de toute
façon dans son rapport a préconisé le
fameux rapport du ronde qui a visé les
infrastructures de traque
déjà repoussée à 2050 la possibilité de
construire ce canal qui a dit que ça
construisent à 10,7
ça coûtait 10 7 milliards d'euros bon
voilà kadji financière je retiens le mot
et puis la question de la ressource en
eau aussi vous vous dites que ça va
produire de l'électricité etc
mais ça va surtout aussi beaucoup coûté
en nous et donc donc pour moi c'est pas
le sujet aujourd'hui donc effectivement
il faut revenir aux frais de ferroviaire
et quand vous dites que la sncf s'en
dégage
il ya dans notre région on a vu des
échecs déjà multimodal elle fonctionne
mais d échec parce qu'on ne finit pas il
reste la vf ca à finir on n'a pas encore
parlé aujourd'hui je voulais en parler
qui part de nantes et qui peut aller
jusqu'à bâle qui reste plus qu' il reste
plus que 160 kilomètres à faire tout a
déjà été fait avant de verre et tout a
été fait après chez jimmy l'avenir sauf
qu'il ya une réalité en france lui sur
les riches moins de produits sur les sur
les trains pour le fret ferroviaire
c'est ça aussi la réalité française 7-6
7-6 si cette ligne là était fini si
cette ligne là était finie on met en
remettrait on remettrait à des
marchandises sur le sur la voie ferrée
de nantes 1 jusqu'à jusqu'à mulhouse
on peut ensuite avoir le corridor le
corridor pour aller jusque jusque
jusqu'en méditerranée le train ce train
pourrait atteindre donc des ports qui
existe déjà dans notre dans notre région
c'est panique à côté à côté d'eux était
ici pas très loin et à partir de ce port
l'a atteint à mériter ralliant c'est un
projet qui est une pure aberration une
aberration économique une aberration
écologique aberration et mais je sais
que monsieur sauvadet la relance est mon
sang
a décidé de se transformer en père noël
c'est tout ce que les
on sait tous que les subventions des
collectivités baisse et lui il dit il
faut relancer le grand canal alors que
ce grand canal on sait que grosso modo
que ce soit la branche par la vallée du
doubs où que ce soit ceux de moselle
c'est à coutras à peu près 25 ou 30
milliards d'euros
alors je ne sais pas où est ce qu'ils se
trouvaient mais bon c'est parce que moi
je suis aussi je sais faire je sais
qu'il peut encore milliards d'euros par
an de financements d'une ignorance
aberration économique aberration
budgétaire mais aussi aberration
écologique
si on passe par le seul modèle on va
avoir des péniches qui vont être obligés
de franchir environ une vingtaine 22
palier sur 200 kilomètres c'est une pure
aberration
c'est une pure aberration et moi je
voulais dire à madame qui représente les
républicains il ya quelque chose de très
très simple vous savez c'est le train ça
coûte beaucoup moins cher et c'est
beaucoup plus écologique essais mais on
n'a pas d'argent dessus si on mettait de
l'argent dessus le monde à une routine
de l'edf ce qui n'est pas électrifié
aujourd'hui ce monsieur qui fournit
depuis servières monsieur qui est venu
depuis nos verres il va nous dire qui
devenu avec une locomotive diesel
pourquoi parce que de nevers à chagny on
est obligé de passer en mode diesel et
il ya plus d'électricité
c'est ça les priorités c'est le rêve
sécurité alors il faut arrêter avec ces
projet démentiel qui se sont jouées
électorale musée par est semblable un
échec dramatique tel muséoparc audience
au niveau de son financement est là
monsieur sauvadet le musée aux partis
anciens et les cités du canal comme ça
ils seront certainement pour le duc de
bourgogne franche comté et tiens on va
construire un canal comme en panne et
une derrière les milliards et le
impressionnant ces 600 millions de
déficit pour l'accepter c'est le réflexe
mais c'était des grandeurs grand écran
mais attendez on on parle depuis tout à
l'heure du ter on n'arrive pas à le
financer on a des vrais problèmes
alors on va mettre plusieurs milliards
dans un bout et dans ce cas là 25 c'est
impressionnant michel neugnot ce qu'il
en pensait c'est impressionnant ça me
plaît c'est qu'on est à côté de la
plaque depuis tout à l'heure on parle
des problèmes financiers
on rame les français en base ils font
payer des impôts et la douleur sur un
grand canal qui va être beau et est une
vision électoraliste parce que monsieur
ce manège du mal à faire sa liste est
innocent je lui fais pas ce que vous
voyez vous l'avenir de la planète
moins d'une minute avant la flash de
midi ce projet a été remis après 2005
ans par le rapport du rouge bien que
l'ensemble de ces que l'ensemble des
projets promis par sarkozy lierait pour
cent vingt ans le financement à 10 120
ans le jeu des faits serre le jeu vous
êtes quand même
laissez moi parler le choix était fait
de faire seine-nord est d'abord donné
celui-ci pour le maintien le moment nous
sommes dans une association que
l'association sel moselle rhône pour
étudier ça ne se fera pas avant 2021 par
contre la baisse cela se fera avant 2021
au niveau de l'électrification donc nous
ce saubade et une constance des gens
2010 déjà en 2004 par contre il a
abandonné les canaux de bourgogne à 6
mai a salué michel leniaud non on va
laisser la place
ces informations il est quasiment midi
donc on va se retrouver avec le flash
d'information en bourgogne et en franche
comté et on poursuit le débat juste
après on va continuer à parler
transports notamment des transports
scolaires à tout à l'heure